-After receiving complaint
from a conservative group,
the Hallmark Channel pulle
several commercials last wee
that showed lesbians
kissing at weddings.
Then, after backlash,
they changed their minds
and put them back on the air
Here to comment is one of ou
writers, Jenny Hagel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Seth.
So, I'm gay, and I'm glad to
hear that the Hallmark Channel
is back on board with having
lesbians in commercials.
But why stop there?
I think they should start making
Hallmark holiday movies
with lesbian leads.
How fun would that be? Yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And to help them out, I'd like
to pitch a few ideas myself.
Alright, hear me out.
"The First Noelle."
Sarah has dated three wome
named Noelle,
but sparks fly when she goes t
a friend's Christmas party
and runs into the first Noelle
"The Nightmare
Before Christmas."
Two lesbians are making
Christmas dinner
when they realize
they're out of quinoa.
"All I Want for Christmas
is Sue."
A woman is hopelessly in lov
with her straight co-worker Sue,
so she writes Santa a letter
asking him to make Sue gay
and Santa does it.
Then there's
"Thanks For Nothing, Santa,"
a sequel told from
Sue's husband's perspective.
"Deck the Halls."
Two female carpenters
get hired to build a deck
the week before Christmas.
But instead of a deck,
they end up building a bridge --
to each other.
"Miracle on 34th Street."
A bunch of lesbians throw
Christmas party on 34th Street
and the miracle is that none o
them have dated each other
And "A Christmas Carol."
It's just the movie "Carol," but
she's wearing this hat.
Hallmark Channel, those pitche
are my Christmas gifts to you.
Back to you, Seth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jenny Hagel, everybody!
Thank you, Jenny!